when physicians asked uh
you know typically they would ask the
pharmaceutical rep or whatever for
information well how long does this drug
stick around
which is a normal thing to ask okay we
call that pharmacokinetics is the fancy
word for it
you know how long does the drug last in
your body before it gets decomposed one
of the fundamental characteristics that
is always an analyzed with any new
pharmaceutical
those studies actually weren't done yep
uh nor were the where does the drug go
in your body the fancy word for that is
pharmacodistribution
and how long is it active that's
pharmacokinetics none of that stuff was
done um he was done to a limited extent
but not rigorously and not looking at
this full cascade that the rna is
actually not really the drug it's sort
of the drug
but the active principle is the thing
the rna makes the protein which makes it
complex and it really doesn't fit
regular vaccine
regulatory paradigms then fast forward
to the present and we have these odd
observations
about immunosuppression
and then we had this paper come out and
sell in january uh from this team from
stanford that did the fine needle
aspirations uh so they actually pulled
cells out of people's bodies it wasn't
in a test tube or in a petri dish
and they said how long does this rna
stick around and it turns out that it
doesn't stick around for half an hour an
hour or two hours which is what the
pharma had been telling the physicians
but in fact it sticks around for at
least 60 days they didn't test beyond
that right and furthermore it produces
more protein in your blood
more spike protein of the remember
this is one of the things i got fact
checked on after our infamous interview
that spike is absolutely not a toxin the
spike that's in the vaccine is not a
toxin
that's what they claimed the spike
has two main components
s2 that kind of stays in the cell and
gets cut from the other part that's
extracellular called s1 that circulates
and binds stage 2 and does all this
wonderful stuff
in the vaccine and in the virus
the s1 is identical
in the vaccine and the virus the s2 is
almost identical
except for it has two little point
mutations two prolines which are there
that makes the
product when it's expressed more
immunogenic from an antibody standpoint
[Music]
you